what's up guys welcome back again to PAX
East 2019 is the island Lord's podcast
and loads of gaming net I'm standing
here with Elena at the THQ Nordic booth
and we're going to be talking about a
brand new game called fade to silence
Elena so tell us a little bit about
yourself what you do as part of the team
yeah sure I work as a narrative designer
for my first games the developer of fade
to silence so I work on the characters
some of the side missions and the cap
scene story management base management
and resource management that's amazing a
lot of games that are considered
survival games don't necessarily focus
on the story elements so that's that's
very interesting is that something that
was that you guys were really focusing
on it was one of the main points when we
developed the game to have it be story
driven to a degree especially we do some
storytelling during the in the world
so when you
explore you find up some trainees that
highlight some story means make you
think what actually happened in this
world so you are stuck here in this
eternal winter with monsters but you
don't know why and you want to try and
figure that it is mostly there's a lot
of environmental storytelling as opposed
to a direct you know sort of very linear
storyline so what type of survival
elements does the game employ in
particular is it is their hunger yes -
Bo
yes turbo yes - Bo there is indeed you
do want to hunt for food or gather for
food so there's both there's you are
constantly exposed to the cold and so
you want to operate you gear make it
warmer if you winter slightly further
north you want to upgrade again because
the further north you go the colder
we have snowstorms if you are not
careful and get into shelter soon and
warm yourself up you can freeze to them
that's amazing and even we have snow
tornadoes so really we're those those
are deadly
that is great so that and that how does
the game differentiate itself from other
survival games besides graphically
graphically if you look at the game it
looks like no other survival game I've
ever seen so we try we try to go this
environmental route so because we
haven't found anything yet that does
what our game does focus so heavy on you
against nature as well well also against
the monsters in there okay so when do
you expect the game to be coming ready
to go and we expect it's currently out
Stephen early XS in early and once it's
done next end of next month
it's gonna be out on Steam PlayStation
and Xbox so guys we have Lords Thai Baht
2 over here playing the game behind us
would you be so kind as to narrate a
little bit of what he's actually doing
in the game
[Music]
recruitment events so in each of the
regions you can find a follower that you
could recruit to help you survive but to
get to them you have to do some
challenging work in this case defeat a
couple of monsters and free that poor
guy from corruption okay now is this is
this helper an NPC or will you be able
to play with other people as well
this helpers an NPC but once you read
your first embassy and convinced him to
join you can and you can play if you
have a friend that also wants the game
he can join you and play ask that
follower and then you can explore
together so it's to play
so what what type of enemies I see that
they're a variety of sort of very weird
looking at a music yes what can use
currently fighting hell mines they
burrow and then pop up and like to fight
you then we have ranged enemies spit
corruption at you and then once once
they get too close they run at you and
explode in your face and then some more
melee based monsters with giant claws
for example and there's many more but so
when you said that its corruption at you
is that a specific state that you have
to do something in particular to get out
of or is that just just damage to you
it's damage in this case and is that
generally how the amateurs quantified in
the game corruption your level of
corruption not necessarily their sort of
fall damage for example someone be
careful when jumping or falling down but
like part of the issue this world has
it's been corrupted by something and
during the story you try to figure out
what is it and what it'll come from
it's amazing looking at it I mean Game
of Thrones with a couple of weeks away
and it feels like I'm playing as Jon
Snow so thank you so much for for your
interview and we're looking forward to
this game I was and I had no idea what
this game was before I came over here
and it looks amazing thank you